foreign
Erickson alongside my close dear
personal friend who have done one other
video with name your name
I am Aaron Alexander hello wow look at
him Aaron Alexander I didn't know his
name had alliteration I love it we're
watching saw two you guys watch us watch
you watched us watch saw one and now
we're gonna watch two okay so you guys
just remember to leave a like leave a
comment and also don't forget to ring
the bell
become a patron because if you are we
call you super sexy and also that means
that you can watch the full reaction
sync up with your own copy and meet in
there and watch the whole movie over
there you guys can watch Greg and John
cover several shows exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch Longs
included are you ready Erin I was going
we're gonna watch saw two in three two
one
[Music]
please
I already feel it
foreign
thing is like crazy
oh okay oh
let's give a clamper on his neck yeah
okay all right I see what we're working
with now the whole Faith thing oh it's
like a bear trap up for your face yeah
hello Michael
I want to play a game the device around
your neck is a death mask
do not locate the key in time the mask
will close think of it like a venus fly
trap
I don't think it's not gonna work give
you a hint as to where I've hidden the
key so listen carefully oh is it inside
of him
hell no make your choice
[Music]
oh my God nope nope no I am not digging
my eye out to get that key but then
maybe I would no
bro what it what
is it a spoon you gotta cut your eye
open put your eye open oh God maybe it's
like at the bottom here and you can just
cut below the eye oh my gosh
yeah no you can't do it absolutely not
oh my God no
[Applause]
with the clock they're really building
that tension too oh my God these camera
moves are making me like
oh my stomach hurts
yeah it's disorienting yes
you're gonna die guy
do it and do it
oh
my God
[Music]
okay all right okay we're in it all
right that's one way to start it okay
saw two hello hi hello and we're back no
thank you oh my God
let's go Daniel
take you long enough
I'm sorry I didn't have a pencil done on
my schedule oh it's Mark doorberg oh
that's who I was like I recognize that
guy
no it's like it's uh it's just like
slubby yeah yeah it's his cousin we're
good at Donnie you're out of your
element I just think I should go back to
Mom's early what did you say I think I
should go back to Mom's well then go
this guy had to walk so Timothy
Charlotte make it run sorry about
yesterday would you uh give me a call
please
what's up
what do you got oh that was a cool cut
yeah it was the arriving officer who
called in is your buddy it was my buddy
he was an informant
yeah it's Mike
oh it's jigsaw yeah
it's his uh his marker can you think of
anyone that would want to do this to you
guys well he's an inform and carry you
unless the possible suspects grab a
phone book look closer to detective
Matthews
ask whoever wrote it feel like the thing
with his son's going to come into play
like his son's going to get kidnapped or
something oh [__] look closer to
detective Matthews oh oh yeah his son's
probably behind that wall or something
not Partners anymore Carrie what about
the fact this guy wrote your name on the
wall huh he asked for you it's not the
first time some psychopath called me out
it just happens yeah like what
some call that homicide I just called it
Thursday
why did you stop being a cop
huh
I feel like something happened between
them
sexual tension
Wilson steel
oh okay these are the best entry points
I don't want to scare any civilians I've
been there before I know the locations
response in there scared the [__] out of
anyone who has to be inside can they
just send SWAT to bust a place down on a
hunch off of a small piece of metal I
don't think so I feel like you have to
get a warrant first right so don't you
have to paperwork yeah yeah yeah I think
you did a judge has to approve it I
don't know they just don't have time for
all that he wakes up from a dream he's
like go to steel or they're like all
right right we're on it
oh there's gonna be a trap I know yep
sure enough
jigsaw
oh God oh
my God it's so creepy yeah oh oh oh
no no I hate it
oh my God Jesus yeah you see this is why
you get a warrant yeah
huh
what is this stuff oh he planned it with
the the legs and the knees dang he was
obsessed with the knees and the legs oh
my God okay
[Music]
there's a person
afraid I can't do that it's actually the
guy oh my God that's the guy from the
first movie it is yeah still dude
who got up at the end oh my gosh yeah I
guess the movie's over the car they
caught the guy all right and that's all
the problems are ever gonna be you have
a right to remain silent yeah you wanted
this why did you want to get caught yeah
like he's gonna do some stinky business
in the I don't know interrogation room
actually I will need to remain here
while you deal with your problem
detective Matthews why this guy
specifically what problem
[Music]
come on guys oh lift out the blankets
what are we doing could be another trap
Tara no no I lived it up come on now
you'd be trigger on the blanket
more people in a mysterious room let's
go oh snap where is his son I don't see
curly hair in there
I think that's my son oh yeah okay yeah
oh yeah there he is there's that boy he
has to be working with people because
how does one old guy just get five
people trapped in a room what is he
doing on that [__] monitor but I
would imagine that um
cowering in a corner with a look on his
face
about two hours before the gas creeping
into his nervous system begins to break
down his body tissue and he begins to
bleed from every orifice here oh my god
oh
yes There Will Be Blood
oh tell me where he is he's in a safe
place
this guy's really good yeah why though
why are you doing this guy his last
dying wish is to kill five children
teenagers as every
every dying man yeah oh God dang it was
every dying man wishes I need to be
short
fish
[Music]
oh
oh nice translation cool wake up
you know that chick yeah um
we in jail no
it's ain't jail man yeah you've done a
lot of time too much
I don't think anybody's listening I
recognize him and her you see the girl
from Seventh Heaven
I feel like she is seventh heaven I saw
this movie on TV last week he wakes up
the next morning he's in his cell with
no windows and no light and he spent
nine years in there something about that
guy reminds me Mark Wahlberg
I meant um what's his name Mark Ruffalo
oh yeah Ruffalo for sure
I hear chicken
[Music]
from okay what's your name
breathe girl
what are you looking for
she knows what's up she knows something
yeah you've done this before you've been
here before yeah right
girl
foreign
[Music]
you walk out that door is to find an
antidote one is inside the safe in front
of you uh the numbers are in the back of
your mind probably literally once you
realize what you all have in common you
will gain a better understanding of why
you're here that's my favorite part the
why Wow
do not attempt to use this key on the
door to this room
you're gonna die
it's all a big goddamn joke and I'm
about to end it
oh except it wasn't the right guy that
got shot not that anyone's right but
you're a dum-dum you just killed that
guy he did
that guy my God
ain't no [__] games
the keys in the back of his head
probably
I feel like when he says in the back of
all your heads and they get matched it
I'm like they would feel something you
would think right like they'd have a
headache I'm gonna ask you again how do
you know all this dude
oh you see the girl from the first one
first that's the girl from the first one
oh it is
oh and she's back down oh baby girl
you're going to second round this is not
good for your soul you got the worst
luck ever Yeah man they said he wants to
talk to me alone maybe you should talk
to him dead I am the one who's been
working on this case from day one I have
been spending every waking moment
piecing it together maybe that's why
you can't understand
it's going through [__] he's right
I don't want to talk to him you already
lost yourself one time before because
you got involved with me but a little
more time all right
Back of Your Mind Over the Rainbow look
in the guy's head they'd showed it for a
reason
[Music]
foreign
oh yeah the key yeah I was like take
that gun out see if there's more bullets
and like you could shoot a lock or
I don't know useful oh the bad okay
where you going I'm gonna find Atlanta
and I'm gonna get out of here
oh God neurotoxin
so scary
Oh no you're not you're not fine girl
no bueno
don't be stupid stupid I know I do not
exit where it says Exit I wouldn't do
that if I was you yeah you're just gonna
keep being dumb why why he wants to die
also why didn't he use it on the other
lock
on the door like why is he oh God this
guy somebody else take the key please
right he is too hot-headed let me get
you guys killed or himself all you have
to do is sit here and talk to me the
jigsaw piece I cut from my subjects was
only ever meant to be a symbol that that
subject was missing something the
survival Instinct they're missing
something aren't you supposed to be
convincing me that I'm your friend it's
a little hard to follow the manual when
you've got my son John hmm
would you have done five years ago how
would you have followed the manual then
would you
get me a glass of water
James oh man that's man
would you get in the water I mean like I
don't have a choice right yeah you know
sit down you got to get them water you
gotta talk to him what's next gotta give
him a sauce sit down and have an 18
course meal any other suggestions
the only door you know how to open is
between your legs oh my God very
uncalled for do they know each other
before did that come out of nowhere I
don't think they did okay then this guy
I mean he's gotta go
what's this guy's role in all this yeah
with the hood up it was down and now
it's back up
that's Joliet right yeah because the
tape said we had more in common than we
know yeah right
say the three of us doing stretches hey
yeah I'd be like you go guy all right
check it out let us know
you're big and strong yeah you got this
what's in that wheelchair no thank you
what is that no no no thank you no what
is it it's a dead guy
oh [__]
hey dead chick
is a Hobie
Avi
it's my name
it's back down inside the device in
front of you are two antidotes for the
boys of the coursing through your veins
one is my gift to you for helping me
kidnap the others
what
I knew he was us wait a minute what does
that mean you see the scar on the back
of his head yes he'd put us here they
can't kill him cause he's the only one
that has the
oh she remembers
oh gross are you sure it's him you
better be sure
oh I'd kill him right there if he didn't
have the you put us in here you can get
us out of here no I can't
are you a dick man
I'm sorry hey we got two antidotes at
the back of that oven wasting time
that's why you can't kill him we don't
even know what's in those syringes you
willing to stick yourself in the arm to
find out yeah uh she's
I mean there's two so which two people
get the antidote well there's a third
one in the safe though upstairs right
y'all gotta find the rest of the safes
I'll kill you where you stand
yeah he doesn't care you don't give up
if you're gonna threaten me with a knife
you may as well cut me a little right
nice the guys all talk what was that
I'm cool looking in my boots
oh it's just like literally right there
wow okay that was easy this is a little
easy yeah
jigsaw smart dude John's smart he's not
it's not gonna be that easy this is a
death trap yeah there's no way right
like because if you just something
that's gonna just do it real quick thank
you Mommy
or like some ass is gonna come down is
it a furnace what did he do yeah
come on get him out of there
um I can't get it open
oh God
somebody call 9-1-1
oh my God you're gonna burn your hand
off but just do it come on buddy oh my
God this is terrible I hate this
oh
[Music]
the Batman
can you no no way it's too small
oh my goodness
that's terrible that's even worse
probably
not only that part of him is out yeah
okay
oh he's dead because I feel like usually
with fire you're dying of smoke
inhalation right so he's probably like
passed out from the pain you would hope
he's like the he means the syringes like
the anecdotes right yeah just
you said you wanted to talk you're
talking but it means nothing
you know it's not
is it like chemo because chemo is also
torture what game was more of a
treatment than a cure I know but it's
like torture yeah why are you so
desperate to get your son back that's
the last thing you said
you said where you left
how do you know that you see the
knowledge of death changes everything if
I were to tell you the exact date and
Dayton I wouldn't want to know no I
don't know can you imagine what it feels
like to have someone suit you down and
tell you that you're dying
it's Gordon have had cancer cancer is an
excuse for what you do the cancer isn't
what started me at my work it was the
moment I decided to end my life
what oh driven myself I and I had failed
oh my body had not been strong enough to
repel cancer cells yet I had lived
through a plunge off a cliff oh wow
my God I was alive and I was determined
to spend the rest of my days killing
other people yeah fabric of human nature
reminding them they're alive through
elaborate traps and torture you've
played before you survived yeah so that
means if he could survive
yeah why did you hit you crazy thought
because
why are you back here
maybe you should talk to the cop who
arrested me
daddy you've never been arrested before
I mean I've been in trouble a few times
you know in and out of stuff my dad's a
cop he's real hard ass
oh God
we found the door
come on
it's gracious I'm gonna come up a little
slower guys uh-huh or say I'm coming up
on you I am here I have arrived we have
found a new story right behind you
what happened also the key the guy threw
down now she has a rope how are these
things gonna come together yeah yeah
okay
take it easy back up all right
oh good thank God it's hitting you buddy
because you're annoying as heck yep
they've been stuck it's a trap
into the lady that survived like she was
right the first time she just said oh my
God
let them be dumb what is gonna happen is
this a delayed thing oh it's a three
minute thing okay you release more gas
yeah that's smart yeah like you're gonna
what with your big muscles open up a
steel case buddy
he doesn't have any noodles up there
if he does have noodles they're very
much they're mushy we're overly cooked
we're overly cooked yeah
listen I ain't crawling into [__] after
that last guy
expires the door in front of you will be
locked forever can you unlock it oh
there's a note in the back get the note
I will give you just
it as to where that key is
the guy who was screaming for the
needles
it has to be you buddy he just said you
have to lie down in the squad that you
exposed to other people that's you
no you can't oh somebody beat him up
oh my God how did everyone worse just
stand there and let him do that
foreign
yeah I mean I would take off my shirt
and give it to her and be like wrap your
hands something like come on y'all
what is he even looking for look there's
so many needles I don't even know oh God
this is awful this is so bad
why did you
I hate this guy I hate him so much
all that for nothing this is where you
go okay you die now ready take all those
needles put it in his eyes his work he's
relishing this threatened to destroy his
work
he doesn't care yeah I don't think he
does something I haven't told you Eric
I'm done listening to you maybe I can
just show it to you brown desk second
you may not remember all those people
but I'm sure they remember you he
arrested all of them
who are the arresting officer in all
their cases and you were the one who
planted all
only to obtain their conviction oh my
gosh your son is playing a game with a
lot of people who don't like you very
much that is a twist
if they discovered who he was
good thing he said my my dad's a real
ball buster instead of a cop what a
twist
you won't possess the combination to
save
thank God the numbers are in the back of
your mind
due to the order can be found okay like
I said tattoo why didn't we see the
other ones
what the [__]
okay good
get him get him
come on
okay yeah
karma [__]
[Music]
foreign
kind of thing you just hate him I just I
hate him also I don't like when people
leave weapons behind in this situation
why is the Sun not affected he hasn't
had any sort of cough or anything
[Music]
oh God good luck the plot thickens wait
you know him yeah the guy who put me
away he set me up
that's rough I don't think you're
supposed to hold the neck like that no
we're not doing anything there
no two are on your own you're not gonna
make it out of there on your own you
guys need to work together yeah
take the bat
eleven okay we gotta move should have
taken them back Gotta Move also with the
bat would be useful you don't know what
order that the combination's in you just
know the numbers
oh no the sign is
his plan here
like shoot him let him bleed a little
bit I don't know like obviously not kill
him
oh Eric
okay I got to go now until your son is
pissing blood
Jesus
[Music]
oh it is so conveniently right there
what's the catch but yeah where where's
this put your hand in there yeah
I don't want it oh
what are you oh my God but I hate it all
oh
if one hand was gonna get high oh why
would you put the other one in there my
goodness
you have to cut your hands off he's just
gonna be like let me see your neck good
luck right
uh yeah she's just gonna bleed today
one two three
okay okay I'm over I'll take you to the
house
oh yeah only him there's a little button
on the wall you better hurry all right
put him in his wheelchair before you
press the button right oh boy come on
all right that was fast
good luck on the house
thank you finally is she gonna grab
do something smart
in that head yeah come on put your foot
on the head pull that puppy out
there you go
yeah let him in
yes oh
I thought they were gonna kill him
come on
what
what does she see
the door oh
okay okay
the key there's a key dropped in there
when we found with the tape recorder
where is it
oh it's
oh my God it was like pounding on the
doors like a lot
nice cut yeah makes it seem super
disorienting
Daniel
sergeant
in the wrong house
is the place with my first one oh it
looks no it looks too big
maybe another sinks
oh
[Music]
oh my goodness
wow
oh okay so now we know he is affected
because he's bleeding from the the mouth
yeah [__]
this freaking guy what is the number in
the back of his neck
it's not your own number
how are you gonna get it if I don't die
good girl
but he's a dummy oh my God this guy
literally does everything in the worst
way possible I hate him so much he's
awful I hate him
oh my God you just could ask her what
your number is
oh my God there's no way you cut that
off like that that's the thinnest slice
of skin I've ever seen where are you a
professional all right get out of here
you should go to culinary school again
yeah I figured give me a break
finally yeah the kid's been fine the
whole for the love of God I still cannot
see you sergeant
Rick do you copy
was it another setup or that wasn't a
lie of taping
oh okay see you sergeant everybody
cannot what is this I do
oh
okay
[Music]
oh I was back there
oh
yep you're right
it's not life
no that's the guy from before in the
bathtub right there's only two in the
first movie
or maybe it's the
oh it's not your son
yeah that's the yeah it's a member at
the very end he was in the or the other
guy
what what was that man what is this
oh
the sun you've ever seen a pig pig
Master hole I don't like it and why does
it have hair I said that before I do not
like it
oh y'all out of time now it's the nerve
gas what are we gonna do and we've got
30's been in effect I know but now it's
like full force right didn't he say like
if the time that you would be I imagine
with the wins the events we've been
watching happened hours ago so if the
nerve gas is already gonna do its thing
it's already done its thing
wasn't that safe oh
my goodness what a
[Music]
twisted girl then wow was she was she in
on it was the girl from the first one in
on it
oh is that a tape recorder for him now
It's gotta be
now he's playing a game
you probably don't even remember me oh
my goodness it is her you sent me to
prison I was guilty of a lot of things
but not the drug charge you framed me
for hmm
the second time somebody changed my life
I was guilty
but my life was saved that day you said
you survived this right yeah I found
myself a father
oh
you must meet death
oh what oh yo the cure for death itself
the answer is immortality
oh no he's trapped down there he asked
for you what do you want I told you he
wants us to survive this I want to play
a game
wow yo my mind is blown dude this is
crazy something I haven't told you Eric
it has I who will carry on John's work
after he dies
are my first test
subject now you are locked away
helpless
oh
game over
wow
did he die there
oh no he's not dead he's smiling wow
oh my God all he had to do was follow
the rule all he had to do was listen oh
my gosh wow holy to Molly
my mind is blown that is insane and he
knew he knew that he was not gonna sit
there not follow the rules yeah because
he knew he would end up so that she
would be able to play in that tape yeah
he played himself he literally he
because he knew he wouldn't be able to
to contain himself that he knew he
wouldn't be able to keep his cool
because he knew it was his character
sure enough
wow oh my goodness
like what a Twist multiple twists but
the that was the biggest twist that is
so many twists I mean first of all like
not a live recording and then second we
find that the sun is in the safe right
and then the third is her yeah but also
that she's like man she's gonna carry it
on she's the Legacy oh my God it's so
creepy when she's like and then I found
myself a father and he's like you have
to experience death so that you know
what it's like to be close to it so
you're more grateful yeah and I'm just
like Oh What A Psycho hey yeah like it's
it's weird and twisted but like it makes
sense it makes absolute sense right
because you're like when you get close
to death you're like oh I'm grateful for
everything now like uh oh I'm grateful
for the Sun and this coffee in my hand
like it it does put stuff into
perspective which uh yeah I mean I think
we're all missing but especially I guess
maybe these characters that he chose in
this film right yeah they were missing
perspective in in what they were doing
in their lives but like
man that girl do like she planned it but
she also had to go through pain to be
thrown in the needle thing too yeah yeah
I don't know if that was something that
was like planned or like probably not
but still she she suffered like she
suffered big time and I also feel like
how did she I mean the thing is she
could have been killed by hot head the
guy we all hated at any point because
he's insane so I wonder if uh it would
have been it would have been kind of fun
for me to see that maybe the whole time
she had like a tiny weapon somehow in
case that guy came after her with that
knife because she could have been a
victim to that guy at any point he's
running around with a bat the knife that
would have been kind of a fun fun little
thing for me to see like oh if it had
gotten that close she she could have
handled it yeah yeah they've had some
sort of contingency plan I think that
would have been a really smart that
would have been cool right to see
and yeah I mean that dumb girl reaching
for the thing with her arm like how are
we how how you don't have to put both
hands in there like that's what I want
to know
and not even I mean you see that it is
going to open and become like a thing
that you could like test it first you
know this is a trap house very literally
like and you're not gonna put something
in there to make sure that this isn't I
don't know a trap like we've you just
saw the guy was burned to death trying
to get his anecdote and you're just like
like that part made me mad
yeah yeah a lot of stuff in this movie
made me mad actually that guy because
there's like there's certain antagonists
that are like oh they're so bad it's
good or you love to hate him yeah just
hate it he was just awful from start to
finish
freaking worse and I'm glad that he got
his comeuppance that the Sun finally
killed him I was wrong about a lot of
stuff in this movie me too and I'm I'm
like mad that I couldn't predict it I'm
happy I couldn't predict it at the same
time oh me too because like I for I saw
the signs early on that she had like cut
herself yeah with the bandages but it
didn't dong on me that like she's the
only person that's been through this
before so maybe there's something more
than meets the eye with this girl you
know yeah no not not at all no I mean
oh I just I feel like also hat making
that guy the guy we hated last to the
end it added a certain amount of like
absolute tension because everyone is
like make please let him die so they had
to keep him around because he he he
ended up with I mean the killer right is
is jigsaw murderer guy is obviously you
know he's he's helping the story Along
being kind of like an antagonist but
like really it was the guy we hated
right like like oh man you better I get
it our lives are in danger in this house
but this guy is about to kill everybody
yeah no jigsaw was like the ACT he was
like the the passive antagonist where
that guy was like the active like in the
moment antagonist because you never know
what he was gonna do he's predictable he
was hot-headed he was Dumb and very
selfish too when they were when clearly
some of them were trying to work
together but they made the decision to
kind of split up and and not really
not even try to really be a team because
they all have their own agendas and they
couldn't they couldn't really stand each
other and I think in situations like
that it's important to like stick
together because maybe just maybe you
guys can solve something you know yeah
yeah it's funny because she also said he
wants us to stay alive she did say that
there's a flashback to her yelling that
at the very beginning yeah and uh I find
it really interesting that the guy we
hate as the second he was in that room
with that guy saying listen we can go
hand to hand in the yard all day but why
don't we just work together he kept
saying let's just come up with a plan
and work together if they had done that
and the the guy we hated just said okay
the numbers are back here I found one
let's all read each other's numbers that
would take a minute a hot second and you
could have opened the safe I get it that
it's like it's kind of a mind [__]
because there's only one anecdote in
that safe right or two and you have
multiple people so it it's making you be
selfish because you're like well if you
tell everybody now we're gonna have to
have a discussion of who gets it right
right but uh it's just like yeah the the
the flashback to her saying he wants us
to like get out of here it makes me like
go like oh if they had just like worked
together I bet you more people could
have actually survived and the sun could
have survived and like except they still
would have been able to trap the dad
like I don't get I can't guarantee it
but I feel like there might be a little
bit where more people could have
survived if they had just worked I think
the thing is the biggest thing that blew
my mind about the movie is the fact that
none of this was actually about them
yeah really all about the cop because
every because they were all convicted by
him yeah his son was there as bait to
try to get him into this situation and
yeah and really he was abusing his role
as an officer to get his quota up or get
his numbers up because you know he was
for some reason or another that we don't
really learn he was already corrupt
years ago before the events of this
story right and yeah I thought that was
probably the most clever thing you know
and it's a more
twisty Turvy has more uh more twists in
the first one I don't know I'm sitting
here wrestling which one I liked more
this movie or the the first movie right
and I think they're both good in their
own merits I think the sequel does a
good job of staying true to the events
and the themes of the first one even
down like the editing and the style yet
it's very much its own story it's not a
copy of the first one at all which I
really appreciate it no and the Callback
to the having the room from the first
one with still the heart on the toilet
what that was great and the bodies are
still in there with the foot cut off
like what
insane and I also like that they did all
get like kind of a note or some more
than others got a tape where it was like
they did all kind of have like there's a
reason they were on probation or being
found but like it was the reason that
they were in jails because the dad did
something right extremely wrong
um which I'd be so I'd be so mad like
they oh god I'd be pissed of course all
of them have a very valid right to be
upset and angry yeah absolutely man I'm
I'll rate it I mean I'm gonna give this
one I really liked it uh I'm gonna I'm
gonna say eight out of ten yeah maybe
like yeah eight out of ten I might say
like 8.5 I think yeah
eight and a half but then I was like I
don't know he does eight and a half I do
eight it's a great it's a great movie I
feel like this one maybe moved felt like
it moved maybe a little bit faster but I
think that was just because there's more
people they were moving around a lot
more the first one plays more with just
two people and adding the tension and
then that reveal at the end is like
that's what sends you over the edge and
this one is like we're we're since we're
all used to the game they had to show us
more of like well let's actually move
around and play it some more if there
was multiple people and they could and
maybe leave it in our brains of like if
they had worked together they could have
possibly survived yeah um versus the two
in the beginning I don't think that
would it would no it's like y'all are
dead I still wondered the relevance of
that first guy though because he was
connected to the cop right right Oh you
mean the guy the guy in the opening was
the face yes right what was it I don't
remember what he mean either I he was
just like the initial he probably just
also was because I think his picture was
in the thing in the folder and he was
also so a person that he that the dad
set up okay right I think so I think
they all were except obviously for the
Sun but uh okay man I mean this is a
great film this this like gets me on
board those saws you guys gonna let us
know if like if saw two are isn't there
like six of these things if like saw
three and the rest are as good they just
I think next month if they come out with
saw 10. next month I knew that there was
a new one coming out it's ten ten of
these things give me a break you gotta
please let us know like does it
deteriorate or does it stay neutral or
get better like tell us what your
favorites are I would love to know but
no spoilers because we have not we have
not seen them
we are on we're on this game together
we'll probably watch more so no spoilers
but I guess rate your saws in the
comments that'd be fun to see yeah
um any last thoughts Aaron
that guy's a dick and I hope I hope we
get more likable characters that we can
follow in the next sauce yeah yeah
likable characters we hated that guy
intricate games I'm I'm I'm about the
games and seeing like the evolution of
this lore now so I'm very curious to see
how it evolves and the first one really
did that with us that was like a long
con game yeah uh maybe they'll go back
to that and the other ones I guess we'll
have to see yeah man all right well we
love you guys that's it leave a like
leave a comment tell us you love us be
nice be cool be kind we love you so much
and we will see you on the next one bye
foreign